[Music]
in every man for himself Jews submitted
by banana peel ha ha ha ha
a new book gives us an inside look at
how government elites have planned to
survive a nuclear attack
oh that's good we need them to survive
this care plan or our plan I think it's
just for that we're going to be
protected
you guys are always right well I want
their plan so that I can do their planet
I can survive like them the old-school
plan is to build a basement with like
five foot or 10 foot of concrete and go
underground yeah that's the old school I
stare down then you get like earthquake
packs I think if I was rich I would
definitely have a bomb shelter just
because I didn't want me to yeah I just
want a bat man cave that's it it's just
kind of cool like I always just wanted
one like a panic room yeah
so you go to the backyard and you open
the latch and inside and a bunch of TV's
magazine a seat up just a whole wall of
spam you would want to go outside
because I would want to build like a
tunnel to get yeah I'd rather have yeah
I don't want to go outside
ha but we're very Colombian you want the
[ __ ] the yeah like the one but it's
clearly just for my childhood
yeah nice are you I'm not thinking like
like good legit way she's thinking it's
this is [ __ ] fun yeah yeah exactly
what I'm thinking of is the book and
then I know I can't go like inside there
there's a whole bunch of weapons I'm
thinking there's a couple of recliners
in a bunch of food and a foosball table
yeah an outsider yeah
oh that's what I'm going to do I'm stock
it up with at least like 15 years with
the food together see um oh was that
movie Brian Frazier watch that one yeah
where he spent like I don't know how
many years underground with his parents
and it's like a many years or something
yeah look a whole home and even like a
backyard and everything is crazy people
that in phenome Anderson I was thinking
I wasn't seen on there but that's
one where he was frozen Oh flash in the
past with Alicia Sony comes up in the
comic book store and he's like what the
[ __ ]
and then so oh I like that one if I get
away from Pasadena that one right I
remember that line yeah he remembers
both older movies yeah it rhymes me like
Bubble Boy mmm
same concept model so this is Garrett's
grass he is the author of this new book
he gets his teeth kun really white I
didn't notice any abnormalities in this
picture good thing I know well now my
eyes are really close together it's not
it if he was an animal he'll be a bird
yeah okay there's no closer this is face
to face with British okay because I
guess I've also looked way older than
the rest of this case now so check out
right here uh if I give a tea right here
everything else just like early thirties
it's okay that is a very symmetrical
face so moving on from his face this is
the superhero
look who's accomplished accomplishments
for second year yeah so it's called
Raven Rock story of the US government
secret plan to save itself while the
rest of us die oh [ __ ] but it is
important for them to save themselves
because we need the infrastructure to be
okay and the civilians if they die such
as myself government still moves unless
you know we're gonna make people laugh
oh that's why we're not they need us
it's high in a time of crisis that's
when you need comedians the most not on
Tom's pretty funny yeah our president
know what think I'm too serious and then
they get all butthurt
he's a delta comedian I know yes so
Garrett he's a national security experts
in though he wrote this book based
partly on newly declassified documents
so that's how do they really get this
information and so he talks about five
places across the entire United States
that have these like underground bunkers
or like these faced bunkers
before these officials in case of
anything happens just five places in the
United
Oh No well these are finally talked
about oh okay any more mm not good
because like if they promise they know
exactly where to bomb the backup please
just been declassified which means they
move their [ __ ] is just brand [ __ ]
new and way better probably in outer
space
okay you know one of them's underwater
you feel like mm oh yeah how do you know
they told us what is it one of them so
one of them it's if the president gets
[ __ ] over some [ __ ] happens in LA they
go to UCLA there's a hidden underground
being of tunnels they showed you where
it was no you're not if you're a student
you get caught in there get kicked out
immediately so you're not allowed to go
into those tunnels but it's under the
school you only see where the entrance
was no I thought one interest but that
one is just it's just one of those
hallways that leads to another hall and
IV to another hallway that lead you to
the tunnel yeah yeah so this person that
they talked about it it's called raven
rock in Pennsylvania and it's a military
conflict that was constructed after
World War two it was originally designed
to be an alternative to the Pentagon in
case anything up in there and so this
place is inside of a hollowed-out
Mountain and has everything a small city
has which is a like they have like a
Fire Department police department
medical facilities
dining halls in like residential areas
it's six miles north of Camp David where
it's the UH on or account davidís yes
for uh it's a Maryland
yeah it's a Island yeah then uh it's
secret not that secret the reason I know
okay the reason why I know is because my
commanding officer at my old unit he was
a guard a former guard at Camp David and
he tells me temp David is a secret
island that the president goes to when
he wants to relax and get away from the
paparazzi and stuff so if the if the
president is like freaking out stressed
out too much [ __ ] going on in the bay he
goes to Camp David and he's extremely
protected and no one else's but there
but the best of the best guards so
that's what can lucky bunch of like
civilians that aren't allowed to talk to
him and they treat him like a normal
human
they think so they try to rob them to
eat them up it feels great being able to
cut them off keys car it just looked
like a damn yeah the entrance to Raven
rocks they should make the parking lot
separate literally in front of the
secret entrance yeah what if there's an
emergency and everyone has to drive out
well that's I mean there might be other
well they do say that they supposedly
have secret tunnels connected to Camp
David to the truth I'm pretty sure that
plans for this because the Pentagon like
you can see it from airspace right and
if that's if that's current operations
and they're not even scared if someone
just flying over just bombing it like I
think they have a lot of you know
surveillance or something you do they
have sensors and stuff like to monitor
the airspace they probably got a force
field yeah so the second one is peers
mountain in Virginia and it's beneath
the Appalachian Mountains and it's
branded as an apt communication station
but it actually houses faces for
hundreds of staff keep the nation
running after this is here is open
that's crazy how to have all these
secret places yeah a bunch of
hillbillies that live around there you
know that one place in downtown where
the Gold's Gym in the Morton steak
houses um I was vlogging there and while
I was blogging the security guard came
up to me sorry I put your camera away
not because I'm telling you but because
that building I forgot it was Wells
Fargo or something it was branded up
like another company is like The Secret
Service is actually in there so if two
people come out and like tuxedos or
whatever suits they just take a camera
which because of that oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I
didn't know that that was it it wasn't
replaying the secret out [ __ ] but I
didn't know what what brand I mean I got
I got what building it was but it's a
fake building in the Secret Service
Service that security guard sucks every
single person by the way he's really
good because it doesn't exist any design
and it works it's part of their planning
in the Secret Service probably has a
canonical data for spy administration so
and now the others non-combative oh not
condemned
our services secret yes so the third one
is called
Mount weather in Virginia and in this
place houses the survivor list which is
six thousand five hundred people that
meet that are needed to help rebuild the
US oh [ __ ] in case like we're on six
thousand so there's a list of six
thousand five hundred very important
people that will that's like a part of
the apocalypse plan
yeah basically they're all white how do
they also have like the alpha male and
the alpha female they're supposed to
[ __ ] and recreate the United States it's
just going to be a bunch of opportunists
buck in rich selfish psychotic
[ __ ] you know that's what
that's all it's going to be what it
should be is like LeBron James is on
that list
you know Marion Jones a u.s. sprinter
see not the Facebook they would have the
craziest kids ever Elon Musk Elon Musk
some other build a genetically people on
top of the Mount
0mr she should be in there too hopefully
got [ __ ] does come oh this is a
understand of man William Dalek so close
that seven stories down yes that's just
that's just longer than the mountain
yeah oh my god they don't stuff like
that
IFS [ __ ] is science dude yeah they all
just oxygen get in that damn talented
build all that stuff that's not like a
crazy man Eddie this is where all of
those who don't even have like luxury
suites for VIP oh my god have like a gym
and they have all this other stuff
see this is what I'm talking about I'm
so poor in life I can't even fathom
something me neither
you know I mean that's like there's like
a certain level of like wealth that we
as regular people think that doesn't
even finding the tip of the iceberg of
what actual wealthy people think like
we're thinking you know when I get money
man I might have this house that has an
elevator inside there let's [ __ ] are you
talking about word have a dinosaur
that's going to lift the
with his mouth and put me here that a
bit like their closet the vault is so
much different than ours I can't even
fathom that yeah my idea of a bunker is
buying a container for $2,000 and
getting that buried you heard our
concept right we still have the
submarine out of it like he has a book
idea
I know [ __ ] so the fourth place is the
North Lawn in the White House like the
insider lawn in the front should ring
underneath that it's the presidential
Emergency Operations Center and it's
only designed to be used for a short
period but they're saying that Obama
ordered a three hundred and seventy six
million upgrade to the facility facility
which was officially approved for her
condition supposedly what a waste of
money 376 million for AC yeah so in the
front lawn the White House and then
there's like a photo like under how
scary is that a tray it's like an old
picture though yeah it's old
if you're the ultimate graffiti artist
you would try to get into these places
and tag up these places that would be
black writings just pow pow pow pow
oh yeah and then the last one is called
a Cheyenne Mountain and earlier on you
just feed hashbrowns down perfect did
now this one is the most famous secret
bunker in America and completed in the
60s built under 2,000 feet of granite
Cheyenne - that's large ast1
I know that is yeah that's where they
have the Stargate can we visit these
places like fort or is it open for
tourism so that means I gotta be in the
military to get in there yes
yeah that's not fair I got to work so
hard it's a step inside bum just that
was the most famous right so if it just
only likes I'm most well known because
it has like the hole and put some people
still can visit you know I can't it's
just like area what is it 51 like we
know about it we can't go there and I
know cuz aliens
yeah but they're saying that this place
it takes up five acres it can hold a
thousand people for a month has six
million gallons of water stored in pools
carved out of rock it's built to deflect
30 Megaton nuclear explosion of closes
one mile away so this water sizes will
build a lot I've been in a top-secret
place and it's only as cool as the
building so I was in camp moujik in
Korea and Pusan and within that camp
there's a secret like North Korea South
Korea war crisis area and so when I was
there I was one of the guys I was
allowed to go in there but because it's
all like vinyl tents it's literally a
guy going you're about to enter a
top-secret area there you go there's
just mud ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
I made it sound so cool yeah but that
place looks cool would you go inside
like some [ __ ] vinyl 10 it's mud all
over the floor you like [ __ ] I
don't care but yeah position looks
insane looks [ __ ] insane there's no
mud in there oh they let you in cause
you're the translator yep the Korean
translator so the big is a television
okay imagine if you got yourself in a
situation you're gonna go state between
North and South Korea and America and
they [ __ ] put you there and you're
sitting there like [ __ ] I don't speak to
[ __ ] yeah
oh [ __ ] goes way to the holy other okay
you're gonna be like Bobby Lee's
character the hot dog that you can't
speak anything like bogey-bogey but I'll
call the real homies I might go North
Korea tell your real homies China to
come down and we'll talk about
alteration hey what's up guys thanks for
watching we are going to regularly start
posting content on the JK films
Instagram so make sure you follow us
there a lot video click over here
[Music]